and they flew me to Vegas and I became
Diana Ross's opening act I believe that
each and every one of us has the power
within ourselves to create the life that
we really want and I want to help give
you the tools to make that happen
I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today on the show Howie Mandel let me
just set the scene up for you so I
arrive you know 45 minutes early for his
interview I'm sitting on the couch I'm
thinking I'm gonna take my notes that
I've done while researching how we and
put them on to my my my blue note card
that I always sit down in front of me so
that I can make sure I you know I have
that they're writing it helps me
remember but also then it's a reference
for if I want to make sure that there's
a topic to dive into like you know it's
just sometimes you get to get into a
conversation and you and you forget to
ask things like how many times have you
been you know argument or in a good
conversation I call man I should have
asked that and and I don't want to do
that with these with these wonderful
people that are giving me this you know
hour hour and a half of their time I
want to get it all in so I make notes
and so I'm over on the couch and here he
goes walking in and he's like are we
ready and I'm like oh god I haven't
written my notes onto the card yet and I
want to make sure I'm prepared and he's
like you don't need those let's just get
going let's just and he keeps talking
and I'm like oh my gosh so I just jot
down like literally almost bullet points
much more much much thinner amount of
information than I normally do and we
sit down and we just go on and on and
and really what I mean we I mean he how
we how he is a full of energy very
positive live in the now kind of guy and
in the show today you're gonna hear how
powerful it can be to be more present
and how detrimental it can be to try and
plan your life and I'm gonna say to hit
home because that's something I try and
do all the time is play in my life and
I'm not I'm not so much of a
go-with-the-flow person so I found it
extremely beneficial and then of course
you're gonna hear all the stories of how
he's been you know wildly successful
just going with the flow so please
joy thanks for having me on the podcast
thank you for doing it my pleasure my
pleasure
I'm a fan you're my first comedian just
to talk to ya okay today I just wanted
to make sure I'm a happily married
clearing that up I'm happily married
have been married for 40 years now and
that we're just talking because a lot of
people are just listening to this so
they hear you say you're my first
comedian and I don't want you know I'm a
happily married how are do you mean turn
this way I mean most of you are gonna
listen they won't even know I guess but
if they're watching so how's your
marriage going you're my first comedian
and how's your marriage going this is
starting pretty awkwardly my marriage is
going good that's my wife right there my
wife is on the podcast you heard she's
flirting with me go ahead after 40 years
that's how you've been married for 40
years
that's how married for 40 years no you
have to ask her you know what she'll
tell you the truth of the matter is
we've been married for 40 years I'm
still on the road all the time the fact
that I spend so much time away is what
makes me so appealing so it's like
you've actually not have me around is to
love me I would imagine people who
aren't listening to this podcast right
now are enjoying me more than the people
who are listening to the podcast so says
my wife yes with a lot of travel dick
you've been married for maybe 10 or 20
years not four I don't think we've spent
10 years together no no no she told me
then are you feeling the edge then if I
do feel an itch there's an ointment for
that I'm always concerned about itches
and burning sensations you know I'm a
germaphobe and I'm a hypercar you know I
do and that's why it's really hard for
it to be to spend any amount of time
with me
I have trouble spending time with me do
you think we can get an hour out of this
or should we try and think you're
talking lower I know you can I'm very
well and so do you think we medicated as
we said do you think that it's the
Canadian in you that makes you so funny
or is it well I don't know
a lot of contributing factors well first
of all take somebody else to tell me as
many people maybe more people think I'm
not funny you know this was Who I am and
I've said this before everything I've
ever been punished for expelled for
gotten in trouble for is what I get paid
for this was considered a behavioral
problem as a child and I've turned it
luckily it became a career I don't know
if you know that but I I don't have a
GED I that's all I've got
well but it's a lot more than me okay I
don't have a GED I didn't go to college
I couldn't finish school I was asked to
leave school and then as luck would have
it on a dare in the 70s I got up on
stage at a comedy club because I don't
dance I don't play sports and comedy
became the rage in the middle of the 70s
there okay so in the mid 70s disco was
big so I told you I don't dance I didn't
go that's when studio 54 I'm very high
yeah I'm in my mid sixties now so so I
went to a comedy club
I'd never seen stand-up comedy live and
they said from the stage the the host of
the show said you know we also at
midnight we have amateurs can get up if
you think you have the chops to do it
and somebody said to me you should do it
now I went okay because I don't ever
because of my mental health issues I
just am very impulsive and I never think
of ramifications so I just said okay and
I thought that would be the joke and I
didn't prepare and people who are
listening at home should know that
Danica does prepared but not used to see
me do a homework I saw you going over
your questions but I don't prepare and I
said okay I'll go onstage I didn't write
any material and if you look at old
YouTube tapes of me you could tell I
don't have a material and and I thought
the joke would be and I never aspired to
be in show business or to be an actor to
be a comedian and they said somebody
said ladies and gentlemen Howie Mandel
and I thought that'll be the joke and I
walked out there and I thought I did it
and then I look out into the audience
and there's people waiting I mean I
didn't think that there'd be people
there and I didn't think I didn't think
I don't
think I didn't think about your great
you live in the present very well I
don't know why I'm medicated but I do
but I'm also I suffer from anxiety and
we'll talk about that in a second but I
got I got on stage and they were looking
at me and I thought oh my god they're
waiting for something so I started if
you look at the tapes I'm very frenetic
it's fear and I start going okay okay
okay okay all right
all right listen to this and I had
nothing but they started giggling at my
nervous tension of going okay and I go
what what what and that was like my act
was what okay okay well do this and
because I'm a germaphobe and I have all
these things I carry rubber gloves with
me because I didn't want to touch and
this was years before Purell years
before access to I didn't want to go
into public restrooms so I carry rubber
gloves and I just pulled it out I went
okay okay okay and I just pulled it on
my head and I started breathing one too
low my nose and the fingers were going
up and down and the audience was roaring
and it popped off my head and the host
came to me and said you got to come back
tomorrow and I went okay I don't know
for what but that be get that rubber
glove on I thought that was a stripper
story what's know is that not the
stripper story
what's the stripper stuff I have a
stripper story I thought you had a
stripper story what is my story make it
up it sounds fun
my dad owned a like a club yeah and that
there was a stripper that you'd see a
stripper every now and again as a kid
and this stripper was naked and like in
a bathtub well I know that that's a
different story there's nothing to do
with rubber glove well you should tell
her first story then what's not a story
it's like I might my dad had a great
sense of humor so he had a club uh-huh
up in Canada and it was a club it was in
a hotel so it's a bar but sometimes
they'd have this stripper called
Princess glow I was like eight years old
if she was a 350 pounds i maked woman in
a giant champagne glass who would soap
herself up then get out of the the glass
and walk around the room and drop her
soapy breasts on bald men's head that
was the story of the of the glove the of
the rubber glove was that you you used
it as like as form of protection you
realize that that's kind of where it
came from
no no no
the robber well I don't know where my
OCD and that I was born with that you
know and as a kid nobody called it a and
you know I was just this weird kid who
didn't want to touch anything and would
do anything not to touch you saw this
with your mom right and your grandma is
it true that's good yes I think my you
know listen I don't think you'd get OCD
from looking but maybe the trigger of
cleanliness or being afraid to touch
things with my hands I actually know
where that came from that came from I
thought and I've talked about that in
the past that they were neurotically
clean but that being said through
therapy they traced it back one time
when there's a little kid I was sitting
on the beach and I got bit by a sand fly
do you know this story no okay I got bit
by a sand fly and I had these it looked
like mosquito bite bumps on me and I it
was really itchy so I scratched it and
when I scratched it the bump would crawl
away under my skin and it freaked me out
like I probably freaks anybody out even
to hear that story yeah and then I went
to a my mom took me to a doctor and
apparently the sand fly had laid its
larva its eggs in me and they were
living all under my skin so that's why
yeah you know and that's a traumatic
story thanks for bringing that up Danica
yeah who's gonna be a light-hearted talk
and that was very traumatic for me and
they showed pretty intense it was pretty
intense yeah and I freaked out I was
like I'm in a book her dermatology they
had never seen this be on you an
immersed human Wow so they took me to a
dermatology convention I was like seven
years old
they lied me on a table in front of a it
was the first audience I ever played in
front of it was there was people
internationally from all over the world
dermatologists sitting there and this
doctor explained what I had and how he
was going to treat it and the way he was
going to treat it was he was going to
burn them out with liquid nitrogen
hmm they didn't give me I was a seven
year old kid oh my god and my
tighty-whities bolted to a table with
500 people watching and then he took out
liquid nitrogen and if you
liquid nitrogen is so cold at birth they
didn't give me anesthetics and he
dropped it on the bump you watched the
bump would start boiling and and and it
come out did your did everything came
out like that I screamed that way I was
being tortured because that he dropped
it on my skin you watched my skin bubble
and burn and blister and then open up
and then whatever was in there would
come out I was screaming my mom in the
minute like once it happened when stop
stop all these people were doing she
undid the the belt and carried me out in
my tighty-whities otherwise to the car
we would never go back to the doctor and
then every night we would pick one of
them and she would take a dry like
almost like a sandpaper ish kind of wash
cloth and rub my skin until it would
break and bleed and then we would remove
all the eggs and that was over a six
month so after that I don't touch things
I'm neurotic maybe I have post-traumatic
stress I don't I have a lot of things
and I am medicated and but that that was
my childhood so that's and it's coming
it's informed things I've done
so maybe because of that I carried
rubber gloves and then the rubber glove
became part of my act and the rubber
glove on the head bought me my first
house so you don't know that darkest
things in the world could end up being
the brightest things in your life you
are present because you are flowing like
you like those things like that rubber
glove you just have it and then you put
it on your head and you go along and
look and this happens and then that
happens and you've achieved so many
things but most people live so far in
the future or live in the past and I
feel I'm getting this feeling like you'd
have no other way but to be right now
well I try to be so that the the problem
is you're exactly right so the problem
is that we all see I think the best
human trait that we all have is instinct
you know in our ink is right and it
really right and even when it's not
right it's the right thing that we
should we should be acting on our
instinct and even if it's not right then
there's a lesson in that path not taken
the truth of the matter is we all over
think you know and I live by what Nikes
just do it and then that's everything
that's happened good in my life are
things that I had no thought which could
have been a problem things I had no
thought about but I just said yes
I just say yes like stand up like
everything in my career everything in my
career if you go through my career but I
always think we get in our own way and
we over shake it we stop it and I think
everybody is as successful in doing what
they're supposed to be doing and they're
in control I think they think they being
people think that other people have
stood in their way or they're waiting
for other people to give them
opportunities right there's just not
mentality a blame game excuses you know
and I'm talking to somebody you right
now I mean a young woman racing cars is
not the plan most people would have
right and it's probably being a reason
to not even if that's your instinct if
you like driving fast and you have that
skill most people would think yeah but
I'm a young lady so I'm I'm not gonna do
that and I would think I'm not a
comedian I'm not in show business I have
no attachment to show business I didn't
even think of comedy as a career and it
happened did you were you know did you
use good you I know what you're gonna
ask was i funny so the point being that
I wasn't I was outrageous and I was
outrageous because I was impulsive so I
would do things I'm not the class clown
you know I was I'll tell you laughter
was a big part of my home you know my
parents were always laughing and my that
they have a great sense of humor and
just I always felt that you know I
wanted to be near where people were
laughing laughing feels good it really
is the best men but I wasn't in you know
I'd go in and they'd be watching the
Tonight Show and there'd be a comic on
and I'd be you know five years old or
six years old I didn't understand what
they were laughing at you know how to
hear the punch line I don't even know
what a mother-in-law is and the guy's
talking about a mother-in-law I'm five
years old the first time I was aware of
what comedy was or my what would make me
laugh
my parents were watching candid camera
you remember candid camera yeah that
isn't it yeah Allen Funt and he
explained to me or I felt like he was
talking to me because he was talking to
the and I'm sitting there with my
parents
and he said here's what I'm gonna do I'm
setting up this fake office and I'm an
act like the boss and I'm hiring the
receptionist and I'm gonna tell her she
can't miss a phone call I'm going for
lunch she's got to answer every phone
and take a message this is imperative
but here's the thing every time the
phone rings and she goes to answer the
phone look at this I have a cable
attached to the leg of the desk it's
going through this wall we're on the
other side so when she reaches for the
phone I'm gonna pull the desk out and
it's gonna go away and we're gonna see
her react I understood it was like being
part of a surprise party I go oh my god
I can't wait for this to happen and I
thought this is great me and my parents
just started laughing waiting the phone
rings she goes to answer it he pulls the
cord the desk goes away and you see her
jaw drop and everything that was like a
guttural you know moment of just
laughter which was a relatable she's a
human being because you're laughing at
her you're laughing at Oh would I
believe what would I do if I was in that
position human reaction it's like those
guys those three guys that have that
show prankster the something that
friends are you talking about
impractical impractical jokers that's
right and how they you know they're
they're like letting you in on the joke
because they've got the IFB in their ear
and they're like tell her she needs to
go to the bathroom and like it's
something simple or something quite
funny but it's not appropriate for the
situation and you know it's coming but
it's the human reaction that's amazing
so it's funny because you talked about
going onto the stage for the first time
and the human reaction to something
simple was was the fun part for you I've
become in my old age comfortable with
discomfort discomfort is the most
relatable we all feel awkward we all
feel like we don't belong we all feel
like we have that dream where you walk
into a party and you're the only one in
your underwear and everybody's looking
you but that's life you know life we're
all competing to be accepted you know
whether you get up in the morning and
you I would imagine you combing your
hair why do you comb your hair so other
people you don't feel like combing your
hair all right there I don't know what
I'm talking about partying it I just
can't decide whether but but what I'm
saying is we live for others we don't
really live for ourselves so that
position I always I was an outcast I was
the littlest kid in school I can show
you a picture but pictures on podcast
don't work but I was you know I just
wanted to meet girls but I was you know
four foot ten in high school you have to
kiss them indirectly were you okay with
that I have to watch kiss them my only
problem is my hands oh really
everything else is fine hand on hand
hand on anything else it's fine yeah I
don't know oh wait hand on hand is the
problem hand on hand on butt is okay I
have three children and things I've done
things you just wear gloves then no you
need to use your hands for some things
no hand on hand I just thought like
after I do that okay I don't shake your
hand and go thank you like I won't shake
your hand but I'll touch anything I
think I think we like add a slight quick
embrace when you came in right I totally
forgot that you didn't I don't remember
but I would hug you okay I would hug you
oh yeah cuz there she is just flirting
again well I think she's flirting again
oh man so that's uncomfortable you're
uncomfortable aren't you no I'm very
confident I didn't say my flirting
tactics are obvious so you would know
you're happily you're happily I'm not
happily married but I'm dating happily
dating yeah yeah yeah you have a hard
time with that because he has his hands
on footballs right so the hand situation
might be a struggle hands and cars I
work gloves all the time I think I
could've dealt with it but let's let's
talk about them I mean let's talk about
that I know mental illness is something
that you know like you say but rather
than mental illness it's mental health
you know and I say mental health should
be equivalent to like your dental health
you know it's really funny it's very
acceptable no stigma if you say you know
I gotta go or have an overbite they'd
given me that's true I mean I do things
for my mental health every day I mean I
wake up and take deep breaths and think
of like a positive like something an
intention for the day like that's part
of my mental health but that's a coping
skill okay so don't we all need a coping
skill yeah but we can't you know if you
say my back hurts ninety people will
give you a card for the chiropractor
mm-hm but if you go I can't function
today because I just don't
I'm just not functioning and mentally
I'm just so depressed or I can't I can't
put I can't put two minutes together I
got to go see a psychiatrist I would
imagine that most of the world
it's kind of frowned upon you know and
unless you have a you know I have a
diagnosed disorder now which I didn't
get diagnosed until I was in my 40s but
with OCD and depression anxiety but what
about just like I why did it take that
long because I'm old and there is a
stigma from a kid that was born in the
50s and grew up in the 60s and 70s there
is a stigma to mental illness
he's even the word mental is maybe it
just could be a description as opposed
to a problem like I mean just because
you've but it wasn't it it doesn't have
to be a problem it can just be part of
who you are it's not a but everybody has
obstacles and everybody stands in their
own way and everybody needs a coping
skill even getting married early tears
well I go get a lot of help I'm as we
speak I'm medicated I'm always in
therapy I put there what happens if you
weren't on medication I don't think I
could survive what does that look like
deep dark depression and I don't you
know have you ever seen like Howard
Hughes you know he ended up in the fetal
position naked peeing into bottles in
his room but I mean that's not far from
where I could be if I was able to even
stay alive you know and I'm all kidding
aside it's just really hard every waking
moment is a battle you know and is is is
hard too and I do it by you talk about
living in the moment but I stay busy I'm
not good with downtime I'm not good with
the voices in my head I'm not good
that's my coping skill that's so
interesting to me because the you know
you talk to so many people and they're
the way that again we're just different
but you know meditation quieting down
you know you know taking a nature a walk
in nature quiet silence and that's how
they reground and that's how they get
back to neutral before they can go
attack whatever it is that they need to
but that doesn't work at all for you
there's been times where I've used
meditation and it has worked but the
truth of the matter is that the busier I
am the more focused I become the better
I become the happier I become it's more
about you know and even if you're doing
it with quiet time you're distracting
yourself from real life
to distraction so they're all
distractions quiet time is a distraction
as much as noisy time isn't it I think
that focusing on nothing well to get
everything else away that's it that's
that's living in the moment that's a
distraction I think that there is an
intuition you talked about it and so you
can't hear that intuitive voice that
feel the resonance in your body with a
physical reaction that might be a gut
reaction to something and if you and if
you constantly stimulate and go out and
do do do you don't get quiet enough to
hear that voice that intuition those
physical reactions to a thought and that
it might not feel good so I think that
you're instead of so the meditation and
the quiet part is meant to get you to a
place where you can hear instead of be
the one talking essentially okay so I
run I'll do it a whole different way
you're right you're right I feel better
that was just a much no I think
everybody needs their own it's just
different
but meditate but we're all different and
we have to all respect each other's
tools I think that a lot of people don't
use their tools or don't figure out or
aren't open to pivoting hmm you know
there are ways that things that have
worked for me in the past that you know
I may end up being just a meditator and
none of this and can't and I'm open to
appealing everything away and doing
whatever gets me through it didn't work
I mean other than that not trying to
bury it you know trying to not say you
know there's an issue and not looking
outside of myself to everybody else
there was you know the reason I don't
want to touch anything the reason I feel
anxious is because everybody else is
filthy and and looking out and I can't
live and I can't sit on that and I can't
touch that and I won't eat that and I
won't and it was like when I realized
that you know what they don't have to
live in my world I have to live in
theirs
you know I'm not this is not my world
it's everybody in how do you cope with
everything else that's going around you
you know it's like the same way as your
world you know my analogy would be like
in your world when you're racing it's
one thing if you're doing laps alone
when there's other how do you cope with
other cars and other you know that's
what life is so you may have this great
laid plan of how you're gonna win this
race if you don't know everybody else's
plan you know and and it changes it
changes your you have to be ready to
pivot change direction things happen
that are out of your control
how do you how do you kind of live in
the moment or how do you you know and
that's the problem with the world the
world has these plans we have these
images we have these these dreams you
know this is the dream this moment this
second is the dream and you've got to
live this moment you said that that is
my problem I am a forward thinker I
think way out and I have dreams and I
want to accomplish them and so I push
through and push through and force
things and I don't flow and I don't live
in the present enough at times and I
think of worst possible outcomes well
let me tell you something as somebody
much older than you I'm telling you from
the perspective of years and years and
years and into your future there's what
I realize that this is what you have
this moment this second right now and
anybody listening to this this is the
only real second there is because mm-hmm
the past is your interpretation of what
happened but that's gone and maybe it
didn't happen that way because he ever
as married couple I could tell you he
said she said
everybody's perspective anything that
happened so that I'm not real it's just
your prospectus not real and your goal
for the future or whatever you think
your plan it didn't happen yet and it
might not happen because something could
stand in your way so the only reality if
you want to really live in reality is
now and if you focus on a goal or
something you want to do really what
you're telling yourself I find that to
be a negative you're telling yourself
well that's what I want to achieve I'm
not there not this I'm not there yeah
and why not make every moment and that's
what I've always done and that's what I
try to do all that stuff like that no
that's what I finally arrived there coz
that's no these are great words that's
wonderful yeah but this is what's my
battle each and every moment
yes that's my battle if I think for a
second about germs if I think for a
second about my craziness and where my
thoughts go and my rituals and whatever
OCD throws my way then I can be in the
deepest darkest hole mentally that I
could possibly be and so right now I'm
talking to you and I don't know what
tomorrow brings I don't know what you
know I have no control over what
happened yesterday hmm and my whole
career has been like that you know I
didn't plan this career I had no idea
that you know 40 years after that dare
I'd be sitting down talking to someone
like you about what I did 40 years ago
how long after that dare how even that
happened 23 okay so how long after that
did you go and I won't do that again
I never did none of it so so I finished
the the set and the owner came over to
me and said mark Breslin from Toronto he
owned a chain of clubs called Yuk Yuk's
he said why don't you come back tomorrow
and I went okay for what he goes no you
do it again Reggie I'll give you a spot
really I didn't even think that was
anything and then I went back and then
it was fun and I got laughs and it was
the first time in my life that I in that
moment because of that fear you know
that's why I like I love fast driving
and I love thrill rides and I love
airplanes and I love that adrenaline
nothing keeps you in the moment like
adrenaline it's chair adrenaline you
can't think of the past you can't think
of the future
so yeah I'll show up again and then I
thought as I told you earlier I don't I
did not like or excel at sports and or
music or anything like that so this was
a great club to go to just like there
are people who you know want to play
poker twice a week and they get together
with their buddies and they play poker
or somebody who isn't a professional
athlete who gets together at the Y and
does one-on-one basketball that's their
their escape their release for the
moment I thought oh I'll go to this club
in downtown Toronto you know I was doing
okay I was in retail I was doing okay in
business I was engaged to be
Reid was this when you were working in
the carpet industry I was in the carpet
blind has a bland huh blind to carpet
man not blind color-block colorblind
yeah yeah blind carpet guy we don't have
to work as well in this room over here I
said in this room over here oh I'm not
in the house but anyway I'm colorblind
but that's okay yeah but but the thing
about it is that I thought oh this is a
great place to hang out when I went out
here I was playing at yuk-yuks three or
four times a week but no aspirations of
saying this can be a career this can be
a this could be something I have nobody
I don't know anybody in show business I
have no connection to show business I
came out here on a vacation
to LA here being LA and because I had
been on at yuk-yuks I had met some
people that were legitimately trying to
be comedians and one of them was a guy
by the name of Mike binder do you know
Mike binder is he
Mike binder is a really right now really
prolific writer director the upside of
anger I think was his movie he did he
did the upside of anger I think there's
she won an Academy Award for that who
starred in that was it Joe now I can't
remember but anyway he writes like
Academy he said I can get you on at the
comedy store and I went out of the
comedy store this is in 1978 or 79 one
night would be fun to do here in
California well I'm on vacation doing
all the touristy things that everybody
was doing and there happened to be a
producer in the audience from the comedy
game show make me laugh and his name's
George Foster and I came offstage and he
said you're interested in doing
television and I thought Elizabeth [ __ ]
this is so Hollywood yeah yeah I'm
interested he goes come by tomorrow and
the first studio studio I ever went to
was KTLA on the Sunset even though he
invited me over he said try to make her
laugh and he was pointing to his
secretary and I just I went okay okay
hear this that's funny that's funny okay
can you tape tomorrow and I go yeah and
I knew nothing about television and we
taped five shows in one day because I
stripped you know and this was a show
make me laugh which didn't Erin
and I flew home how long was each
segment they had to do for the show so
you had the the show make me laugh was
you had one minute 60 seconds to make a
contestant laugh and for every second
they didn't laugh they won money so it's
hard enough to make people laugh but it
was instead of to not laugh incentive to
not look like it isn't hard enough
anyhow so anyway I did the show and I
was crazy and I had voices and different
things and and then I flew back and I
had a great story to tell about my my
time down in California that didn't air
in Canada but it aired here in in
California or wherever in the States
and I started getting calls I got a call
from the Mike Douglas show do you know
what that is
you're too young Merv Griffin okay you
know he was yeah so I got a call from
they were these daytime talk shows way
before Ellen or Rosie that and I got a
calls they said we saw your make me
laugh what'd you come and do the show
and I couldn't believe it
again I went yeah I'll come down and do
the show and I went and did those shows
I did the Merv Griffin Show but I would
fly in and then fly back and do the show
but I did the Merv Griffin Show and I
get a call from the Merv Griffin Show
after the Merv Griffin Show aired from
gene Simmons of KISS oh yeah yeah I did
I didn't yeah but I knew would kiss who
kiss was yeah and gene Simmons calls and
says I saw you on Merv Griffin yesterday
afternoon and oh my god guy from kiss is
phoning me look will you be an opening
act have you ever been in an opening act
from will you be an opening act for my
girlfriend and I went oh okay yeah I'll
do that who's your girlfriend and I'm
thinking you're just asking me what kind
of verse Rd or yeah like oh what's an
opening act for a girlfriend but he goes
he was living with at the time Diana
Ross no I didn't know that and I became
a nanny she's in Vegas and they flew me
to Vegas and I became Diana Ross's
opening act and the audience hated me I
was horrible like I had nothing I had
the rubber glove I have pictures of
myself on stage at Caesars I'll tell you
that that Caesar story so I'll and I
landed Caesars yeah you know and I go
backstage at Caesar's Palace on the
doors my name Howie Mandel oh my gosh
with two L's no but it didn't matter you
know everybody knows my guess my name
right till stood still today it's okay
but it's not - else it's six everybody
could sell so I had my name shortened
for show business but and a guy comes
and says we need you to do twenty
minutes tonight and I said okay he goes
do you understand what I just said I go
you said you need twenty minutes he goes
do you understand what I'm saying I go
twenty minutes he goes not 21
not 19 oh wow that's what I thought oh
wow how do I do that and now today I'm
wearing a watch but I didn't
I don't wear watch I'm only wearing this
cuz it's got like a Fitbit on it but I
don't I don't wear jewelry I have not no
no watches and I go how am I gonna do
that I know what I'll do
so I gave some guy backstage 20 bucks if
I would work in front of the curtain and
she had her whole orchestra behind the
curtain and the reason they wanted at 20
is because her show was perfectly timed
and at that time it was more about the
getting out to the casino so she did an
hour and I did 20 so that's 80 minutes
and then boom the people are not there
Caesars Palace didn't care about people
coming to see Diana Ross they want the
people to come and see Diana Ross lose
all their money to gamble right and in
fact you're sitting in front of that
booth right there is the center both
users oh yes
I'm Caesars the original Caesars they
tore down that room to make the
Colosseum which they built for Celine
Dion oh yeah but the original Caesars
Palace Circus Maximus showroom - yeah
that's the center booth that's the booth
that was in that room when I played that
so anyway I gave a guy 20 bucks and I
said okay just when it's 19 minutes bang
on the that doesn't sound like the floor
that's a table but bang on the floor
behind me right behind the curtain and I
know in one minute I can take that glove
out I'll close with the glove over my
head and blow it out
so I anyway the first night starts and
though the lights go down the audience
roars you can hear the announcement
ladies and gentlemen Caesars Palace is
proud to present an evening of Diana
Ross and the crowd goes crazy and if you
listen really closely and I was probably
the only one that did you could hear but
first Howie Mandel
you know and I walked out on the stage
and just to a I'm sorry I keep getting
the table just to the see of
disappointment you know this is not what
they paid to come see this is not what
they want to do and I only worked a lip
at the stage and the people sitting on
front in the front of the stage would I
look down and they would be pounding on
my toes on my shoe and I'd look at them
and they'd go they'd mouth get the [ __ ]
off of it because they came to see they
pay big money see Diana Ross and I was
this lowly comic that was just acting
silly and going okay what what and you
could see I have a picture my wife took
a picture of me on stage I'm wearing a
sports jacket you can see the sweat
stains through the sport I'm just you
know then finally after what seems like
an eternity of silence you know I I hear
boom boom boom on the floor behind me
and I go oh my god that's like the
saving the best sound they've ever heard
yeah so I'm gonna close with the glove
and I take the glove and I inflate it
over my head and it's still silent you
feel stupid when you're saying things
and nobody's reacting of course standing
in front of a group of strangers a
couple thousand strangers in the rubber
glove on your head and it's just silence
and I'm thinking I just pray this is
like double-double with latex maybe
they're roaring I'm sure they're all
laughing and it pops off my head it just
silence and people are looking at me and
then that's it finally I got to say
ladies and gentlemen enjoy Diana Ross
and they roar again
and I turn around and I try to get
through the curtain the the guys
supposed to page the curtain for me yeah
and he's holding it closed from the
other side and the applause is dying
down and it's more quiet and more quiet
and more cool and I can hear him going
what another 10 another 10 oh and I Turk
that's what usually those are the words
from inside my own mind and I turn
around in the audience is just sitting
there going what's happening I'd have to
do another 10 I have no more material I
am soaked I blew up the rubber glove and
I go Jews here from out of town and sick
and then finally I hear boom boom boom
again I go goodnight and they let me
through the curtain what would it
happened this I had only done 10 minutes
I was dying somebody walked by somebody
by backstage that wasn't a signal I'd
only done in ten minutes
oh my god and she wasn't ready to come
out total truth time goes this so slow
and you're suffering and the thing was
that every night I went on
they hated me nobody enjoyed me nobody
saw me one night sony rented out the
whole room there wasn't a person sony
from japan that there wasn't one person
did you know which was probably the best
I know because they like the glove
that's the one thing they love but every
night but Diana Ross would stand there
was one let you know how they say if you
could make one person laugh well I
didn't know this she would laugh at the
side she would laugh and then after a
week I get called into her dressing room
but if I go thank god they're gonna put
this me out of my misery
she's gonna fire me and she she sat me
down she goes can I talk to you and I go
yeah good plan ready please just release
me she goes you are so funny
I love you and I would like to offer you
the whole rest of the run can you pipe
in some some some people laughing a few
times and everyday I just were they
laughing over they not laughing were
they laughing you couldn't hear them
very well no they were not they were not
laughs I love your the glass half-full
kind of girl
no no but know that there was no laughs
there was no love like and I get the
whole run I just went to her 75th
birthday that's me and her I have a
picture over there she just invited me I
still have a place near and dear in my
heart and she was one of my first
supporters that's amazing well in your
field you know you you get judged all
the time right are you funny are you not
funny
what was that bit like and you know you
don't get the job or you get fired
really quickly whatever it may be
although I haven't heard you're getting
fired other than being not let to stay
at school other than that you seem to be
you know I'm aware of what but what's
that like I mean that's I think that's
something that's a reality in life is
being rejected and turned down but we
always as comics feel rejected even when
it's going well so when you tell you
what how do you deal with that I don't
my wife has to deal with it so that this
is the thing one of the highlights of my
career was in the 80s they booked me I
was selling out but they booked me at
Radio City Music Hall and it sold out in
an hour too and then they said can we
put another show up for the same guy
said yeah then we sold out that so a two
shows Radio City Music Hall I'm just
this little kid from Toronto you know
this goofball
and we went and I did the first show and
my wife and I go up in the dressing room
and we're looking down on 7th Avenue you
know I'm from Toronto Canada the suburbs
we've never seen anything like this
7,000 people are piling into the street
you know on 7th Avenue and 7,000 people
the same time are coming into the next
show
there's stanchions and cops and they're
directing traffic and the midtown
Manhattan is 15,000 in the middle of
everything right in the middle of people
are all there for Howie Mandel and my
wife looks over at me because we're
looking out the window and she goes
isn't this amazing and I don't wanna
yeah maybe
and she goes what do you what do you
tell me what you're thinking and this is
what I was thinking and I think it's
kind of indicative of what a lot of how
a lot of comics think is I thought this
is New York there's 10 million people
here you know what that means 9 million
eight hundred and eighty five thousand
people don't give a [ __ ] that I'm in
this town they didn't show up they
didn't buy a ticket they have no reason
to like me and we always focus on that
you know self-deprecation is always a
win right so do you feel like some of
that is just inherent in the in the tone
of comedy well I think most people
whether you say it out loud or not most
people are not really that sure of
themselves you know what am i if you
know if you have to think about it but I
always like I tell a story about how you
know I was on stage and I was in this
big concert and people are roaring and
laughing and going crazy and I mean I've
just and I see I look down in the front
row and there's one guy one guy's no eye
contact nothing and he's not laughing
and you know nobody else in the room
notices that but every comic will tell
you you start to play to the one place
that isn't giving you anything
yeah so I fight and I don't know why I
did this I like this I go can I hang on
a second can we just stop this the guy
in the blue sweater you're not looking
at me the [ __ ] is wrong with you
everybody else is roaring what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you
you don't even look at me and the lady
beside him goes he's blind and oh my god
my heart just
robson to my stomach he laughs at
because what I went because I repeat it
he's blind like out loud and everybody
who could feel a full like crashing oh
yes that's all [ __ ] you couldn't have
said it better yourself that you did say
it yourself but an audience and and I
just and now I'm in a hole
I'm in like a dark cavernous anti comedy
hole and I don't know why it hit me but
I love these moments when I'm living in
the moment and I didn't know there was
nothing I could say but I did say I'm
not making fun of the fact that he's
blind but I do have a question why the
[ __ ] would you buy a blind man front row
seems like why does that make put him in
the balcony and lie to him and tell him
these are front row seats why the [ __ ]
and then I got the audience back but
that's what hit me naturally but that's
it lucky moments and you know [ __ ] is
thrown everybody's way and sometimes you
create your own [ __ ] but you got to be
able to pivot and get out of it in that
moment you gotta you know so impressive
the off-the-cuff I mean I get the
impression like you said that when you
were performing for a Diane I like you
you know the time was up and you thought
man I don't have anymore anymore Conte
and like any more jokes anymore and more
things to say and then you had 10 more
minutes but you also seem very
off-the-cuff and very like improv like
where you just kind of let it go how
much how much is well in my business now
in my business now you call it off the
cup and improvisation and you could also
refer to the exact same thing is
unprepared that's what I am I just don't
like that's why it's fascinated if it
doesn't don't know that they're
listening to this you come at this
because you've been asking me questions
you've done homework you you prepare you
were and maybe that's because of your
background maybe you have to I don't
know what goes into driving you know I'm
at the worst driver in the world I don't
think it's driving I think it's having
been in the and being the one
interviewed so many times that if they
don't know anything about me and they
ask questions that are clearly not deep
or right even I had someone say that I
went to college and like I don't even
finish high school buddy
but they don't know about you but did
you prepare did you prepare for even
what you did for sports did you see I
don't prepare lasts actually less maybe
I died wasn't a big fan of like studying
because you could get data from so our
cars had an ECU on board with all kinds
of sensors all over the car and so it is
electrical I don't know either it's just
called it's okay like the muscle on your
motherboard had the mother you had all
the analytics available to you sensors
on the car into the ECU the motherboard
and so you could get steering angles you
could get speed traces throttle trace
brake tree that's why I'm a bad driver
oh I never had any of that yeah my wife
doesn't let me drive anymore oh really
no she won't let me buy any car I like
to call you got a speedometer in there
that helps no but I like cars CI a DHD
is also a I think I'm the spokesperson
for adult ADHD I you know I get
distracted very easily driving is
probably not your thing man
no I took even flying lessons and the
guy told me they quit this is not for me
I don't have the acumen that that
wouldn't have been a I feel like that
but I did like I like cars I bought some
nice cars and yeah I'm not name-dropping
but I bought like one time I bought a
Ferrari
yeah like the forever and here's the
problem you could take to attract follow
the lines no that wasn't my problem so
my problem was that like this why she
won't let me drive standard anymore so I
had a Ferrari and then once I got home
and I saw that I was at my house I
finished and I got out of the car and I
went in the house and then I would hear
her screaming my wife oh no that's a
little kind of like that and then I
looked back and the car I didn't put it
in the park I didn't put it in the car I
just get out the engine was running the
the airship was in neutral and my wife
would be rolling back out of the
driveway across the street into the
fence of the neighborhood and that
happened like three times she goes to
finish when you're driving just finish
just finish she says the same thing when
we're having sex
how much oh well but I don't forget with
that I don't forget driving in sex you
can have a sex drive and I am standard
hi where would standard but she does the
shifting no see what I did there
yeah that was a lot of linking up of
great little sexual Linden innuendos
that is well tonight we're gonna try it
with an ECU oh yeah yeah oh gosh that's
that's the love of fun distraction what
oh it actually makes me think of
something that is like so it's such a
how now it's kind of like a shitty turn
in the world where everybody takes
everything so personally you talk let it
go correctness yeah anything you can't
do anything you can't make a joke no you
can't not have an opinion in a fact like
on social media if you don't like talk
about something horrible going on in the
world having no opinion is still having
an opinion and like there's just nothing
you can do anymore that appeases that is
okay generally well so how does that
affect it cuz like you guys get to go I
always said when I was younger I'm like
I wish I could be a comedian because you
could say anything you want then and
it's all okay cuz it's in the name of
comedy well that used to be in the name
of comedy used to say something somebody
get offended and you go I'm just joking
you can't you can lose your whole you
know especially somebody like me who's
on you know family-friendly television
I'm on America's Got Talent or Deal or
No Deal hey you know I do I still do
stand-up and and and I take my first
special in 20 years which is
downloadable and you guys know it but
the truth of the matter is when I
finally came out here and I made the
move to come out here my inspiration and
the the person that kind of moved me the
most was I watched Richard Pryor mmm-hmm
and I watched Richard Pryor each and
every night get on stage and write live
you're probably too young to remember
but he did it he did what I believe is
one of the most seminal comedy films
ever it's called live from the Sunset
Strip in fact it preceded that's what
Eddie Murphy that was his God for
delirious and everybody who went on to
do and he was the first guy that I saw
on stage at The Comedy Store working his
wares and and and do you remember
Richard Pryor and you know he is but his
is his tact was you know before that you
know the only the most respected
african-american comic was like Bill
Cosby who kind of made up jokes about
his brother and family and things like
that he Richard Pryor was the first one
that said you know what that's so not me
and he grew up in a brothel and he's he
had relationship problems and drug
problems and he used to talk about this
on stage and you I don't know that you
can put yourself in that position but in
the in the 70s the things that he was
talking about and the people that he was
depicting our jaw dropping like and it
was rough and sometimes he'd find that
line across that line you were in the
room when he crossed I went okay okay
back off of that and I saw this is the
art form the art form is to be brave and
just to try it and you know put the
pedal to the metal of your terms but but
the thing was and and and then that's
what allowed me to be like kind of very
open and in the moment not think about
like not there's a freedom there there
was a freedom I went away and went away
with the advent of cell phones it went
away when they could take a picture or
social media as you call it you know
media when I started out was journalists
it wasn't the guy who sits alone in his
underpants on his bed tweeting right now
that's no history of knowing anything
about the subject or context or content
you know perception seems to be truth
these days you know whatever you breathe
no you're right I am right I'm never
wrong that's what I will you tell my
wife that I'm right yes I will thank you
for flirting with you at the beginning
I'll cover that up I'll help you in any
way I can but but what I'm saying is
people started tweeting things and and
saying they saw or they said things or
out of context and then political
correctness has taken away our freedom
of speech especially in the world of
comedy and even doing this podcast right
now I have thoughts that I would never
have about watching what I say or how I
how I'm saying something could be
perceived and taken out of context or
interpret it in a way that
could possibly lose me one of my jobs
it's um you know like even now that your
brother now that we brought it up and
we're talking about it even the fact
that I jokingly said at the beginning oh
you're flirting with me this is my guys
like well you wouldn't do that if you
had a male host you wouldn't do that
anything could be taken out of context
and it's just in fun and it's just but
not everything's fun anymore and they've
taken the what would a phone like what's
the what's the phone as a symbol really
I mean like it's that's the that's the
delivery mechanism for seeing and
hearing what's going on but just clip it
I do you think that's more of more of
the problem because they can still see
it an entirety and be like wow I can't
believe you'd say still are offended
even if they have a Content right but
you take elephants so you take that
context along with their byline yeah you
know whoever tweeted at their byline
look at him making fun of lately created
the person oh he's a misogynistic you
know even if you see it in totality they
can still create the perception by
saying can you believe he said this well
the fact that people jump on all these
lonely people at home it become they
they're under the guise of media it's
social media but it's not really media
but that's what we consume now yeah and
that's how we make decisions media now
we get more facts from social media than
we do from newspapers or news well news
and even news reports on stories not on
facts news reports on you know what they
said or you know how this is interpreted
yeah it's not even when I was a kid I
sound like an old man now but growing up
and watching Walter Cronkite he gave me
the facts and then I could just form my
own opinion now you watch news probably
went out and got on themselves even
right but now you watch news and you're
you're aware of what their opinion of
what they're saying is which i think is
kind of wrong from a news i just want
just give me the facts you give me the
facts and then i'll all have an opinion
about those facts they're a solution for
this yes what is it
no i'm sure there is i don't know what
it is but your good question there is a
so i don't know i just think that we all
have to be aware and concern you know i
have grandchildren now and i'm so scared
of them growing up in this world that
has social media and they have access to
so much and so much has access to them
it's kind of a scarier world now you
know not only for comedy not only for
broadcasting not only for it's just a
real scary world but we have to be aware
we have to live in the moment and if
something happens we got to be able to
pivot and people don't pivot you know
people get we we love comfort and
comfort is being stuck in our ways you
know and you know this is every single
day in every waking moment is
uncomfortable for me and but I feel that
that keeps that's why I'm alive I don't
want to feel you know you want to go on
a roller coaster you want to drive
really fast if I went on a roller
coaster and they said oh you're gonna
love this the breeze goes through your
hair and there's no real Hills and
there's no drops that would just be
boring and it doesn't make you feel
alive but if you'd that first drop or
that speed or your gut being thrown
upside down I need to just be in that
moment and the world is making it harder
and harder and harder to take those
chances and take those drops and to make
those leaps and whether those leaps and
drops are done with words or comedy or
an opinion mmm do you think that it's
your you know all of the things that you
face on a daily basis that are
challenging that puts you in this mode
of being more present and being able to
pivot and not thinking ahead because
it's just not your you know not worrying
about that not being not almost being
able to on some level do you think that
that is maybe who you are today and with
that great perspective and that ability
to adapt and pivot or do you think
that's just who you are without no I'm
cognizant of working it and pushing it
and doing it because I don't think
that's I don't think that's where we lie
I don't think that's where we rest
that's not our resting place in fact
when we met and we talked about it
before I saw you preparing I said no no
no no that's just talk let's talk don't
prepare don't be I don't want this time
I don't want to think I don't want to
worry about what you're gonna ask me I
don't want to think about what you're
gonna ask me I just want to talk and I
you know that carries into everything
that I do I just want to I want to show
up you know you met rich who works with
me he goes ahead for he produces all my
shows but he'll go ahead and say listen
even if I'm gonna do a radio interview
no just don't
let's soon
he's just talked to him and start the
interview as soon as we get to the place
let's just do the show I don't want to
get scared I don't want to get nervous I
just want to just be I want that
nervousness and that energy to be used
for whatever it is that I'm doing I
don't want too much planning everything
I've ever planned in life has not gone
well anything I didn't plan ended me in
a better place if I've gotten there on
instinct you know I didn't plan to be a
comedian
I didn't plan to act you know when I was
a comedian when I did have a plan the
plan was everybody at the time Robin
Williams and Billy Crystal and all these
people were moving from sin of comedy
into sitcoms so I decided to do a sitcom
and I went had a general meeting at Mt m
which is Mary Tyler Moore's company and
that was the home of all sitcom it just
so happens at the time they were
launching their first dramas and they
were shooting a drama and they had been
shooting for a week they had 13 episodes
to shoot and they didn't like the
dailies every day they look at what they
had filmed they didn't like it and they
decided to recast so when I sat down at
MTM Molly lopata said to me can you act
I don't know but you know I think I'm
funny and I think I can you know if you
had to pick she goes read this and I
read these sides and there was just this
dramatic piece there she goes that's
very good come down the hall and I went
down the hall and I had to read the same
thing for these guys didn't know who
they were then but it was Bruce Paltrow
winneth ya father and Mark tinker grant
tinker was Mary Tyler Moore's husband
and I read that same thing again they
went thank you and I went home and my
wife said to me how was it I go I don't
think it went well they said thank you
halfway through and I don't care because
it didn't seem that funny anyhow and
then I got a call this is a Friday you
start Monday started in what they go you
got the show I go what show and I got
the show called st. elsewhere and it for
six years it was a drama it's probably
before your time do you know what it was
Denzel Washington started on that show
with me me and Denzel started on that
show and it was a drama huh they did
Hill Street Blues insane elsewhere the
first two dramas out of MTM I did that
show from 82 to 87 I became a dramatic
actor and the guy I replaced was a guy
by the name of David Paymer who went on
to win an Academy Award playing Billy
Crystal's
they're in mr. Saturday night Wow so I
didn't know and then to follow this
storyline I my career kind of took off
and I was doing really well through the
80s through the beginning of the 90s in
the middle of the 90s it really started
to wing I wasn't selling tickets anymore
I was sitting in casting offices
unfolding chairs auditioning for five
lines and I got a call from my manager
saying NBC wants you to do a game show
and I went no [ __ ] way and you have
to if you put yourself back in the
beginning of the 2000s no comedian had
done a game show since Groucho Marx
which is also before your time Groucho
Marx had a show called you bet your life
but no comedian had done game shows in
fact as a comedian the game show host
was the punchline you know I didn't want
to be a game show and they said this is
a huge show it's all over the world the
last market is is America and I go no
and they go why I go this will put on my
career is over that's it this will put a
nail this is that's it I will not do
this they call me back an hour later
they said can they just pitch you and I
said no and then they calls me back an
hour later he goes he just wants to meet
you he'll go wherever you are you know
let them just explain the show to you I
went okay I'm in Jerry's deli in the
valley if he shows up here and I'll show
you after I have the card this guy Rob
Smith shows up at Jerry's moves my soup
and he had made a card he'd he didn't
even go to Kinko's it looks like a an 8
year old after it's a cut out piece of
paper I still have it here and he showed
me Deal or No Deal there's no questions
there's no skills he's telling me
there's 26 models we're gonna open cases
for an hour this is [ __ ] this is not a
game yeah this is nothing I go home and
I told you this kind of is a testament
to how rough it is to live with me my
wife says did you take the job I go no
she goes take the [ __ ] deal they just
take the deal go get out of the house so
I was so scared I so I said I phone the
back on there's a Friday yeah I phoned
them back and I said ok I'll do it
and they were thank god I go when does
it tape they go Monday mm-hm I go well
don't you have to build a set they go we
have to say
well don't you have to hire models we
have the models how far down the list
was I how many people had said no before
I said I think about that when they
asked me something in its last minute
they're like hey you know can you come
do this appearance next Wednesday or do
this I'm like dude who canceled so
anyway I said can I hire writers and I
hired they said yeah so I hired writers
and I thought okay I'll be on NBC
they're gonna do five nights of
primetime they never did that before
I'll hire writers I thought of all this
funny comedy I was gonna be witty I was
gonna be charming I was gonna fall I was
gonna start selling tickets again and I
walked out there's a picture right there
that I'll show you after that's Karen
Van that's the first episode that lady
with the case number for love up above
and I walked out and they went ladies
and gentleman welcome to Deal or No Deal
this is Howie Mandel and I looked at
that lady as close as I'm standing to
her as close as I'm sitting to you and
it looked in her eyes I said tell me
about yourself and she goes you know I'm
a single mother I have three children
I'd never owned a home I don't have
hospital I don't have health insurance
or anything and then I realized and
you've now been on sets a lot you know
that people who aren't around television
or maybe not around tracks or whatever
they get there you could see that
there's a fog over so yeah they're not
present the opposite they're just in a
fog and I was so afraid to distract her
with the comedy because I saw the kids
sitting there and this is a real person
yeah and I became a human but first and
foremost I am a human being but I'm a
father and I'm a husband and I looked at
her and I thought if I distracted you
because the first offer was like five
graduate oh no deal and smashed at No
Deal and I'm thinking $5,000 you live
someplace in the middle of anything you
don't have anything how could you just
say that you didn't even think you
didn't even give me like I want to hear
your thought process so I thought I
can't do comedy and that kind of changed
my cadence so I threw away all my comedy
and I said you know what it doesn't
matter life is much more important yeah
I just want you to leave in a better
place than you came here well yeah so I
would say the offer is $25,000 the way
you would talk to a five-year-old right
watch it like you're me understand the
gravity of the situation here and what
this could do for your life so then I
ended up taping five shows didn't know
comedy I was so beside myself I thought
I had just humiliated myself on national
because you thought you were supposed to
do comedy
I did nothing is the first time in my
life I had not done a voice you know I
do cartoon voices I had not done comedy
had not done anything funny I just
wanted you to walk out of here in a
better position so I said to my wife
this is gonna air next week let's get on
a plane we went way down south in the
Caribbean where there was no TV I just
wanted to get away I just couldn't take
the unslung of humiliation that was
about to overcome me and I got a call on
Tuesday morning after it aired and from
that guy who showed up at Jerry's he
goes you're not gonna believe this this
went through the roof I go what went
through the roof he goes a show we went
through the roof he calls me back on
Tuesday it's even higher Wednesday it's
even higher I flew back I landed in
Miami the first person within 30 seconds
just looked at me when Deal or No Deal
it was a one time where I thought about
it and I was gonna walk away my wife
saved me was the best decision I've
never had a bigger success in my life
that's why I have a production company
that would that brought you know I had
very separate audiences there people
that knew me as a stand-up with the
glove on my head those weren't the same
people that knew the character I was
doing on the people were watching
dramatic television on NBC that was show
I did with it I had bets they said that
was dr. Fisk açaí have a bet with my
husband his doctor Fisk is the same as
the goofball that puts the rubber glove
on their head you know this is male at
the time so nobody knew I was that I had
a Saturday morning cartoon oh wow called
Bobby's world but that was single mother
evident single mother there was just
mother sitting there with her kids they
didn't know that I was the voice so the
I know all these separate audiences then
Deal or No Deal brought them all
together so I'd like to say you're
welcome Steve Harvey so cuz after that
the next show that came on are you
smarter than a 5th grader they hired
Jeff Foxworthy didn't they hired Bob
Saget then they just started hiring the
family comedians before that comedians
didn't felt amazing to not be your stick
like not do not play the role that you
had been paid to play for so like so
long and while you're talking about like
lots of different capacities they're all
about being comedian right
no not insane elsewhere but but the
truth of the matter was there was
something incredibly validating about
being accepted for just being a human
being instead of being funny or being a
really good doctor or be
a funny voice yeah you know the gizmo or
you know we were laughing at the
beginning because we were like going
back and forth and I'm over there
writing my notes down cuz you know
you're uh you're amazing showed up early
and Here I am going home in I'm not
prepared now and you're like stop doing
that and I started asking a question you
like just sit down just start asking me
that and what I was gonna ask you was as
a comedian do you do you always feel
like you have to be funny and my back
story is that when I drove Indy cars
David Letterman was one of my owners and
I got that feeling like he everywhere he
went he like felt like he always had to
be funny
and is that the case that's the that's
an exterior that that's I feel like
people when they recognize you expect
you to be so at this point in my life I
can't deliver that you know and I'm not
always funny and again that's when I
talked about we kind of do everything in
life for others you know you comb your
hair you put on makeup you dress because
it's about others you know you're not
showing up and the most comfortable so
when you have this persona mm-hm
they expect you to be funny and that's a
hard expectation that burden I do and I
don't think I'm not funny and I don't
like jokes
I like awkward situations if I can
create an awkward situation and we're a
lock were together there's no I give you
a high-five right now but that's hand
hand but you're good like that
but I'll give you the fist there you go
there you go well bump but what I'm
saying is people but and then sometimes
you get in a predicament where you're
not trying to be funny and they think
you're being funny
hmm like I've gone to a restaurant
opening and you know I ordered the veal
and then they put down penne pasta and
the owner comes over and Easter remember
these you like the pasta I go but I
ordered the veal you comedians get it I
go with that I don't get it it's not a
joke I really nice see what he's doing
he's saying you're the
you're doing it's not a joke
I'm not joking I'm just so it's hard
sometimes you want people to know that
you're serious and you don't get it hey
GT come around a GT was just an offer
and I'll tell you it was you know after
I finished the allure No Deal and NBC my
friend Jeff gaspin who was an executive
there said how would you feel about
judging and I said oh okay
I didn't know what I was getting into
and I watch i watch i watch everything
everything I'm fascinated by anybody
who's willing to get in front of people
and do whatever it is all about that yes
so so I did it I didn't realize you know
I'd spent my entire being trying to be
accepted you know you want people to
like you we all we all do so the first
time when I started on a GT we used to
travel the show now we're now we as
judges are just in LA but we still we'd
be in Dallas and we're gonna see all the
acts from Dallas and then but you know
you'd say somebody would sing and even
if they were bad that was their hometown
kid you know and I'd go I didn't like
that song and then he'd have 3,000
people in the theater booing you I've
never been in that kind of position yes
Simon Cowell how to deal with that he
loves that drivin that arrives in that
but let me tell you a little bit about
Simon Simon thrives in that mode but
that's not who he is he is just
incredibly honest so he was a record
executive that got a chance to do and
your producer gave him his first job and
and sat with him in eighth we were
talking before the show before anybody
even recognized him but he was an A&R
guy he was a record producer
so you come in and when you would
audition for a record he was asked to do
what he did we never saw that on
American television where somebody's
just honest he created the whole genre I
think of these judging and talent shows
of the way they are instead of just
being nutty if they were if they were
not that than it was the gong show where
they were supposed to be bad but he's
the one that was honest and what they
didn't show and I don't know if they
showed it on they didn't show it on Idol
but and they didn't really show it on
our shows too much is if he's honest and
we feel that some of these feelings got
hurt as soon as they go to commercial he
is the first one to jump on the page on
the stage
give them a hug and tell them and be you
know constructive and comfort them and
so he cares about kids he cares about
animals he has a heart but that honesty
that brutal honesty it's just in him he
can't he can't lie and truth is true
sometimes it doesn't know I mean I would
say that in my life like I am a truth
seeker no matter how much it hurts or no
matter how and but you know what it's
true yeah that's really true it's so if
you said to Aaron do these pants make my
butt look big yeah yeah I do know you do
know you don't I see I do i I really
don't ya you're lying I think you're
lying you're right no I'm not I really
am I really would want to know I want
the true think you want to know until
you hear the truth I don't think you
want to know that he'll say you look
beautiful let's go
I'm just hoping his perception is is
that no matter what I look beautiful I
thought you wanted the truth I thought I
wish that just oh man I just hope that's
his truth no it's not I would have met
you're very beautiful but no and even if
you do I'm not looking at your butt
because you're sitting on it but even if
you do there's there's beauty in that I
think the Kardashians have created an
entire industry yeah yeah mm-hmm yeah
yep right not proportionate some partly
we are there their butts are way too big
that's your taste mmm that's true that's
nobody so you like big butts you cannot
lie write it down write that down that
you should write down that could be a
song or something no I'm serious I'm
telling you I don't know that much about
music but I'm telling you that could be
a hit you know speaking of because I
feel like they're that kind of leads
into so much of like a fake world of
like what's really important and what do
we really want in life and you know
you're 63 right yeah mmm what do you
want now like what's important to you
now well my children maybe what's
different like what's different now that
that used to be important to you that's
not and you've realized you know what
I'm 63 I finally realized this well just
you've got to be comfortable with
yourself and reach
expect I just the one word that I feel
that we don't have enough of in this
world is respect you know and I tried to
teach as a parent my kids to respect
everybody everything that just we don't
have respect
we just don't respect if somebody is
different than you thinks different than
you are different than you come from a
different place there seems to be a
disrespect like your way is right and my
way is right in your piece of [ __ ]
immediate judgment yeah and and even
judging and I'm saying this is I'm the
judge judge but but even if I don't love
what you're doing or what you stand for
I respect you I mean I have nothing over
anybody else or anything else I just
think that we lack respect in this world
and social media is kind of the
adrenaline for disrespect because I
think that people can be incredibly
disrespectful and hurtful in the
anonymity of their own room and behind
their own thumbs and they say hurtful
you know and even you and I being on
television or being in a podcast it's
really funny how they you know my mom
used to teach me if you if you don't
have anything nice to say don't say
anything at all there's no reason for
that but I think because you're on TV or
they know you you know somebody will
come up to you and say things you know I
used to like you had thick curly hair I
don't like the bald why did you shave
like why are you saying that like you're
not a human fatter and put it in the Box
you lift fatter in person but even if
even if I'm just a guy from television
who tells another person you look fatter
in person is that good is that why I
like when they tell me you're so much
smaller in person I'm like mmhmm Thanks
so what are you saying and you say no
I'm not I'm not smaller in person I'm
exactly the same size wherever I go and
what is your point yeah you know and you
should say and you are I'm gonna be
honest and don't take this badly but you
are uglier in person mm-hmm say that to
the person that says it to you and then
they give me how could you say that how
could you say but being small is not a
bad thing you don't care about your
height do you no no no I
in the personal way of like your thought
thinner in person is that dude is that a
bad thing to mail in security what oh
you always wanna be skinny right like
you said it didn't bother you these are
the pants make your butt look big
oh my god ladies and gentlemen is the
circle of life and the circle of
Danica's pants apparently you know what
you are oh is right
thank you and I do respect you and I
warn you I'm such a big fan thank you
you're wonderful I like people who do
things that are out of the box and you
are certainly the epitome of out of the
box don't judge a book by it's cover if
people didn't know you and they looked
at you they would never guess what you
did for a living not only what you did
for a living would you Excel that for a
living in now yeah I'll be honest with
you
you're excelling at this this is really
good this was a I do a lot of these
you're really wonderful I wish you much
success in many many years
thank you thank you for having me
[Music]
you
[Music]
you